- That was some classic
Janet Jackson for you.
You're welcome.
We have someone very special on the line
who's deeply connected to that song.
In fact, she sang that song and in fact,
I was nervous as hell singing it for her.
Give it up for Ms. Janet Jackson y'all!
(hands clapping)
(crowd cheering)
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna be
really honest with you.
I am sweating so much from singing
and you can hear it so well.
Anyway, you made me very nervous ma'am,
but thank you for letting me
sing another one of your songs.
I love covering your music.
- I love the way you cover my music.
I think you're and
absolutely wonderful singer
and I love to hear it, so thank you.
- Oh my gosh, and also
I want to say this too,
because you not only tweeted
me, after Escapade I died,
when I did Escapade, but
you did something so nice
and you've sent me flowers
and a little messages,
it was so sweet and I was
having such a hard time.
So thank you so much, you
have no idea what it meant.
So I just wanted to
say thank you for that.